françois gay et préposés aux
bénéficiaires depuis 1991
au fil des ans il a vu la tâche
s'alourdir
mais son salaire n'a pas augmenté en
conséquence ça fait des années qu'on dit
que les salaires sont pas à la hauteur
de la tâche de la responsabilité
préposés aux bénéficiaires
c'est dommage qu'on soit en pandémie
présentement puis qu'on est on négocie
pendant que nos aînés semeur dans le
secteur public les préposés aux
bénéficiaires gagne 20 55 à 22 dollars
35 leur ceux qui travaillent auprès de
résidents atteints de la coved 19 comme
jonathan grenier ont une prime
temporaire de 8% manque toujours de
personnel donc c'est bien difficile de
travailler sur la pression de la
rapidité pour asi de donner le meilleur
pour un patient à l'étranger à la fin
alors ben a changé des pilotes l'emploi
il peu attrayant les conditions
difficiles alors qu'on cherche partout
embaucher de nouveaux préposés
les syndicats réclament des hausses
salariales ça ne pourrait pas être en
bas de 25 $ de l'heure nous on demande 3
$ dollars c'est une demande minimale
mais ils voient que ça pourrait être
plus le premier ministre l'a dit il
regrette de ne pas avoir aussi plutôt la
rémunération des préposés mais le geste
pourrait avoir des répercussions en
augmentant le salaire des préposés aux
bénéficiaires d'un secteur public dans
les c est celle des publics par exemple
ça vaut mettre une pression sur les
salaires dans le secteur privé au privé
le salaire moyen est de 13 à 14 dollars
leur plus une prime temporaire de 4
dollars
certains syndicats réclament que le
gouvernement décrète une hausse
salariale
une proposition qui ne tient pas la
route selon des propriétaires de
résidences privées 500 résidences ont
fermé leurs portes au cours des
dernières années
d'autres résidences vivre de grandes
difficultés financières
une augmentation imposé mettait
simplement la clé dans la porte de
beaucoup beaucoup de résidences pour
aînés
les propriétaires de résidences privées
demandent l'aide financière de québec
pour augmenter les salaires de leurs
préposés sans quoi ils partiront vers le
secteur public ici olivier bâche un
réseau canada montréal